so we get to ride in an Uber with the
Uber CEO yeah that'd be pretty cool do
you get special treatment on the app I
do not get special treatments yeah I
would call an electric car right now
whose comes first yours or mine it's an
Open Marketplace it depends you never
know who comes in first all right let's
do it let's pick our destination you can
see lots of options you can go Comfort
electric you can go green you can get
shared you can get a line scooter
there's like 10 options right now more
than 10 options a lot of options are you
at all
overwhelming consumers you know going
green is gonna take some time and we
want to give as many choices to
Consumers so that they can pick to go
green on their terms but let's go
Comfort electric since there are two of
us in the car
[Music]
here's Haley hello Hi how are you I'm
good
what is Uber's current carbon footprint
it's pretty significant generally the
footprint is based on essentially all
the miles driven we completed two
billion trips to this last quarter and
we've got to do everything that we can
in order to reduce that footprint and we
committed that by 2030 in the US and
Europe and Canada we're going to be all
electric and by 2040 we're going to be
electric all over the world that's an
ambitious Target
Uber wants to cut emissions entirely so
for this ride hailing giant that means
getting to Total electrification which
would be nothing short of a green
Miracle it's all part of the company's
sustainability agenda called go get zero
so the paintball picture for me this
whole go get zero push
what's the goal and how will you get
there the goal is to go electric and
create the incentives for drivers to go
electric as quickly as possible and
Riders to pick electric as well so the
smart charging technology is allowing
drivers to know when and where to charge
to feel safe to get routes that are
efficient then on the rider side one new
feature that we're introducing is
actually a feature for you to see how
much you're saving in terms of emissions
so when you get that green car or when
you get that Comfort electric we'll show
you how much you're helping out the
environment how many emissions you're
saving we have to get that flywheel
together we need drivers to choose
electric and then we're going to put
more and more electric options in front
consumers as well how much more does it
cost to ride electric if you're taking
green actually it's the same exact price
as an uberX so are you taking the hit on
that or does the driver take the head on
that where it cost we take a hit so
we've we've said that we are investing
800 million dollars in the transition to
electric and we've got to make it
economically sensible for drivers so for
example our take rate on electric rides
is lower because right now generally EVS
cost more than combustion right
[Music]
our driver is going to buy electric
there's the sticker shock gas prices
inflation like it's expensive it is
expensive and you've got to start some
somewhere and what we're seeing now is
first of all prices are coming down
right Tesla prices are coming down but
at the same time for example we're
partnering up with Hertz to allow
drivers who may not be able to afford
that EV the option to rent uh electric
vehicles as well in a very affordable
manner so I asked my driver today my
Uber driver today
if you would switch to electric and he
said absolutely not he said the Grid's
not ready what about the range anxiety
what about the time it takes to charge
when you could be you could be driving
you could be making money yeah those are
real issues and I do think that as a to
charging we're introducing now smart
charge and routing technology how does
that work what it does is when you go
out and start driving based on your
earnings opportunity in city we will
identify smart locations for you to
charge will tell you when you should
charge because even the charging costs
go up and down on a daily basis or based
on different locations and another
really cool technology that we're
introducing is actually smart routing as
well we use AI algorithms so that if
let's say you're at a 25 charger 30
charge we won't send you on a really
long trip well we're not going to send
you on a trip that is in a charting
desert we're going to make sure that
there are plenty of chargers around last
tech that we're introducing is actually
for airport so for example you can go to
airports and you can charge but you can
keep your place in line so that as soon
as you're done charging you can go pick
up traveler coming in
[Music]
time to charge up all right yes it is
does the charge time bother you I mean
and I'm status yeah
um it's different and it's something to
get used to I don't like waiting too
long before I have to go why did you buy
a Tesla the pricing like with gas right
now is so expensive I come from spending
400 a week to spending 150 a week and
that's a major deal wow especially when
it comes to budgeting do you think
Uber's treating drivers right
I do I think they should be able to pay
a little more I think the benefit should
be better like what like Health Care
paid time off um just regular benefits
that you know every other job gets
yeah when we started out no one believed
in they were in EVS there were no one
was producing EVs and now the industry
has accepted that electric vehicles are
the future so it's pretty wild
do you talk to Elon much
I've taught them a couple times usually
we talk about electrification right we
want more Teslas on our Fleet I think it
is great that they're aggressively
lowering prices because now Teslas are
becoming more affordable now there is a
question about the brand Elon has taken
a big reputational hit
tap into Twitter I've heard not a few
people say my next car is not going to
be a touch how does that play out I
think it's tough to tell uh the fact is
that Teslas are the highest selling cars
in terms of electric vehicles by mile at
the same time we're not you know we want
electrification to happen uh and that's
not just going to happen with Tesla you
know we need Fords out there GMS out
there Toyota's out there Etc we need all
these other players to go electricity
the biggest obstacle is
getting all of these independent parties
all of these companies all of these
governments and then consumers
to work together in a way for single
goal which is electrification or so
we're saying hey let's as Uber we should
take a lead on electrification and in
the end it's good business to go green
right
San Francisco still hasn't recovered
from the pandemic
what are Uber levels well when we look
at San Francisco in terms of uber and
how it's come back pre uh pandemic San
Francisco honestly is
pretty low on a global basis in terms of
trips we're well above pre-pandemic
level we're going through a particularly
difficult time but uh never bet against
the tech sector and never bet against
San Francisco coming back well I hope
you're right because it's my home too
foreign